PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
This week, we're
talking about
migrating, streaming,
and generating insights
with your data on BigQuery.
I'm Priyanka, and welcome to
"This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Traditional data
warehouses can be
expensive and
difficult to maintain
as data rapidly increases in
volume, velocity, and variety.
We know that businesses are
turning to BigQuery to keep up,
so we've put together
a quick guide on how
to start your migration plan.
Get prepared by creating
a migration plan
and then going through the full
data warehouse migration guide.
Storing data in
cloud storage helps
you not only keep your
files accessible and secure
but also gets them ready
for real time analysis.
By using Cloud
Functions, you can
run code every time
a file is uploaded
and stream the
data into BigQuery.
Follow along and try it out for
yourself in the solution guide.
Now that you can move
more data to BigQuery,
we're also making it easier
to work with your data
using persistent User
Defined Functions.
Felipe has another
great post detailing out
how to create and share UDF's
across your organization.
Check out the details
to create your own
or use the ones that
Felipe has shared.
Looking for some more guided
practice with BigQuery?
We'll unroll in From
Data to Insights
with GCP specialization
on Coursera.
You learn how to query and
process petabytes of data
on BigQuery.
It's got interactive
scenarios and hands-on labs
to give you meaningful practice
at skills that have never
been more relevant.
Enroll today.
If you want to read more
about this announcement
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.